grammatical gender is the concept found
about a quarter of the world's languages
but you can sort all nouns into male or
female la or la in French the B or das
in German the das is for neuter ins and
a which is found with a few countries in
Central Africa there are four
grammatical genders human male human
female element and Finland there are
even occasional languages with more
complicated systems than that
now I'm a descriptivists linguist I am
NOT meant to judge whether language
features a good or bad I'm just meant to
describe what they do but grammatical
gender is just such a stupid concept I
sort of hate myself for saying that but
it is really silly so that's so that's a
computer is it French a computer so it's
male all computers are male and that's a
bottle French really so it's female all
bottles are female really should I dress
it up in a frigging pink apron and give
it a rolling pin as well descriptivism
don't judge I'm exaggerating I am
exaggerating but I genuinely have tried
searching the literature for any
advantages of grammatical gender there's
only one vaguely convincing argument
which is that it can help clear up
ambiguities and speed up recognition of
words by a small amount okay but 3/4 of
the world's language has managed just
fine without it
and meanwhile grammatical gender causes
a heck of a lot of problems first
problem it affects the way you think one
has to describe a key German speakers
who classify key as male were likely to
associate it with words such as hard
heavy and jagged
whereas Spanish speakers who classify
key as female or more likely to say it
was golden intricate and little that
also says a lot about gender roles and
society but my word that's something I
am not qualified to talk about second
problem it's really clunky job adverts
in languages with a grammatical gender
have to either use both terms or a half
assed marker to clarify that they're
asking for anyone what brings me to
English English doesn't have grammatical
gender it used to in Old English and
we've still got a couple of words like
blonde and blonde that change depending
on gender but we don't for worry about
filing everything into one box or
another but what we do have is the
third-person pronouns he she and it and
that is a
if I want to refer to you the viewer I
have to use the pronoun he or she which
is ludicrous for several reasons one its
none will be three syllables and it
sounds awful two there are folks who
don't fit into or don't want to declare
us either of those categories and if
that surprises you you need to get out
more since it is a bit dehumanizing
there's really no suitable English
pronoun to use except English does have
a solution and lots of people are using
it and a lot of the old stick-in-the-mud
folks hate it the answer is they
Facebook is using vague I signed up to
Facebook before they started asking for
gender I have never actually told them
that I'm a guy so my friends see Tom
Scott updated their profile picture and
you know what that sounds absolutely
fine to me it just seems normal now
let's go depend on your dialect whether
it sounds good to you but brace yourself
because singular BAE is running very
fast but you didn't even notice when I
used it in the very first sentence of
this video and it's got history even
Shakespeare used it but yet because they
sounds natural
it gets around the problem of trying to
force invented pronouns into English
which let's be honest has never actually
worked so there you go I've gone against
my descriptive his training and said
that one linguistic trait is better than
another and you know what I'm okay with
that because some people are they get
over it